hey 42 here new research claims that
almost all dinosaurs had feathers
welcome to R if you have a turd in your
teeth was a common insult in 17th
century England Matt LeBlanc was down to
his last 11 dollars when he got the part
of Jerry in friends two-thirds of all
bankruptcies in the u.s. are caused by
medical bills the busiest polling
station in the Australian elections is
in London Wales can't taste anything but
salt more than 80,000 bartenders in
America have university degrees there's
a tree in South Africa so big that a
pope has been built inside its trunk
hermit crabs form gangs to steal shells
from other hermit crabs
you could shutter a diamond with a
hammer diamonds may be one of nature's
hardest materials but they're not the
toughest there's a difference the
toughest gemstone is actually nephrite
Jade the world's largest chicken nugget
is twice the size of the world's largest
chicken half the world's population has
a genetic mutation that makes Brussels
sprouts taste extremely nasty a quarter
pounder weighs less than a fifth of a
pound when cooked people who try to stop
thinking about chocolate eat more of it
than those who don't the first time that
Hitler and Mussolini met Mussolini
described Hitler as a mad little clown
due to a computer error in 1981 41
thousand Parisians received letters
charging them with murder extortion and
prostitution
instead of traffic offenses thanks for
the view subscribe for more thoughty2